foreign
because I was going to make a sandwich
okay
let's do it
[Music]
what do I think about heroes
well we've all seen them haven't we
swatting about the place
with their disproportionately high
cheekbones and comically massive weapons
roughing up Bandits because they like to
rough up Bandits don't they living it up
with the common folk every single night
on a day-to-day basis I'll say the two
Heroes me someone who's breaking you
ground with fruit with veg on the
agricultural side of things just look at
them not wafting around mythical
creatures
that's what they are wafters yeah well
done you see I'm not here to slay
legendary beasts I'm here to conquer the
vegetable not a euphemism let's face it
the age of Heroes is over this is the
age of innovation this if you will is
the age of death
one moment
this is awkward
yeah
[Music]
foreign